when you made this investment in
people's piece um
i think you it was an auction you paid
twice as much as the previous
highest bid uh and is that correct
no no i like christie's has a very
interesting bidding system so you cannot
bid whatever you want right like it's
it's 250k
more than the previous bidder that's it
oh okay so do you know who you were
bidding against were there
many people at the end or was it just
you versus one other person and who was
that person
um i i don't know him personally and i i
didn't know
at the time of of the bit but you know
it i found that it was justin sun
through christie's and and also his
twitter
got it and so why was it so important
for you to own this piece
um i think it's a very important piece
in nft history so if you look at my
collection personal collection i've been
collecting
very important pieces that that marked
uh the change of medium and the
importance of medium
as nfts have come through
like from starting 2017 right so i've
had these
collection of programmable art the first
uh
official collectibles like from f1 um
to this specific piece that that i felt
like was
was signaling to the world the
traditional world that nfts are here and
nfts are here to stay
um there is a lot a lot of things going
on right like and
and people think about a lot of
analogies all the time when when
when we think about something new and
every analogy is a
little wrong right and that's what gives
this a lot of value
because it's you know that there's so
much to talk about it
yeah and i and like frankly speaking
i had like i felt like i had to do it
and
and it had a lot of value going forward
for a lot of reasons
so you believe that this piece will be
worth
much more in the next 10 or 20 years
uh so i'm not planning to sell it so
first
first of all and it's always a good
starting point at creating scarcity good
you clearly are very sophisticated in
how the art world works
even if you're new to it so you're never
going to sell it
but if it did go for sale do you think
it's going to
think it's going to appreciate in value
so like i i don't think it's a bad
investment right like i didn't buy it
so that i like for the appreciation but
i
i definitely think this is going to be
because there's a first piece
in in a very important change and and
the kind of attention it got in the
world
is is phenomenal right like and
everything plays into it right
so that's that's the thing uh nft is
actually capture the art of off the
moment
more than anything and and that's what
like you know dapper labs
also captured very well and and if you
look at
what's a lot what what nfts have a lot
of value is the ones that can capture
the moment
and and kind of become really unique and
it's very rare so
these this people pieces has become so
rare
in the sea of nfts you know you're able
to see it separately and everyone
almost knows about this nft in the world
today right so i think it's very
valuable
and we are going to have like so many
billionaires coming out of crypto in the
next decade
uh let's wait till bitcoin hits a
million dollars and
yeah a lot of people are going to want
this